I miss being a part of something
important I still think there's a dark
army connection here don't waste my time
you're trying to destroy me it was a
moment of weakness what am I doing here
why are you trying to shut me out it's
you hey guys Pete here it's gonna be my
mr. robot season 3 episode 2 trailer
breakdown there was a short teaser that
they showed after the episode and I'm
gonna break it down frame by frame more
or less and talk about what we learned
there's also been the synopsis the
episode synopsis that came out so we'll
look at that it says Elliot is lit by
his goal to undo 5 9 Darlene is caught
between a rock and a hard place and mr.
robot sparks a panic the trailer starts
out with Elliot outside the e-court
building we've seen this before but now
we have a little bit of context he's
probably just showing up for his first
day of work
we saw him mattel Angela he needed to
get a job there and it looks like that
part is going through there's a
voiceover here of Elliot he says I miss
being a part of something important now
that probably isn't connected to the
idea of him working at Ecore but we do
know he's trying to undo what happened
with 5/9 so I guess in a way it could be
related to that him getting inside at a
corp is related to him trying to turn
back the clock on the things that
happened after the hack went through we
see Dom in front of a computer with two
screens zoomed in but the focus is on
her so you can't really tell what's
happening on the screen if I had to
guess I would say they're looking at the
scene where Cisco was shot on the left
side it looks like CCTV footage and it
looks like Santiago is behind her but
the person is obscured and then there's
some code and
linux shell thing going on on the right
side her voiceover says I still think
there's a dark army connection here
which is basically what leads me to
think that they're talking about the
crime scene where a Cisco is shot
someone's wearing an F Society mask and
making a new video I would imagine this
is related to the synopsis and it's
saying that mr. robot sparks a panic
there's no way to tell for sure who's
making the video but that seems like the
best guess to me otherwise I'm not sure
what that's referring to mr. robot
starting a panic next we have a shot of
Elliot that we first saw in the close
your eyes trailer this is probably the
hypnotherapy Christa says that will help
Elliot he closed his eyes sans the
voice-over telling him to do so and
there's a shot of White Rose as Minister
Jane she says don't waste my time she's
in a room that doesn't look familiar to
me in this short clip but I'm pretty
sure we see it again later which I'll
talk about after that there's an aerial
view of Elliot and Darlene on the
boardwalk at night this is also
something we'll see again later there's
a shot of the FBI escorting someone out
of the E Court building I can't tell who
it is but my thinking is that it could
be related to the femtocell or something
else from that period of time we know
the FBI's been there that they were
there whenever that happened so that's
why I'm guessing that it's related to
that the next voice over is mr. robot
and we see him on the screen he says
you're trying to destroy me I have no
reason to believe he's talking to anyone
other than Elliot here that's been going
on for quite a while Elliot trying to
destroy him and now especially since we
have this idea of Elliot getting
hypnotized by Christa and picking up on
his meds again there's a shot of the
emoji headed people on the subway this
was in a Facebook teaser before the
season it has all the hallmarks of being
a dialogue of Elliot talking with us
it's on the subway it's definitely kind
of imaginary looking I don't think this
is real people with emoji heads but
we'll have to wait and see after that we
see Elliot walking down the street
there's a woman leaning
against the fence it could be Darlene
it's not clear enough to say for sure
though that cuts to him pulling his hood
down with a concerned look on his face
and Joanna's voiceover starts at this
point we hear her say it was a moment of
weakness it's kind of cut in with this
shot of Phillip price it's a quick thing
where he's in a room with Chinese
decoration this is most likely where we
saw Minister Jiang earlier as the two
are probably having a conversation it
could be an embassy type building in the
US or price could be in China I leaned
towards them being in New York but
that's just my guess it cuts into
Johanna on the screen and the voiceover
sinks up
she's miked up and there's an American
flag behind her the mic makes you think
she's on TV but I have no idea why the
flag is so prominently displayed here
this could be an interview related to
the Scott Knowles incident since that
seems to have been her plan to get
herself out of what amounted to her and
being and hiding almost I mean she was
allowed to move around but she was
avoiding everything because of all the
negative press that could also be
related to Tyrell but not sure what she
would be talking about there on
television we see an intriguing shot of
mr. Sutherland right after that he's
headed back to his SUV and the car
behind him has someone slumped against
it looking dead that makes me think that
old mr. Sutherland is still knocking off
people for Joana but without contact who
knows go back to the boardwalk Elliott
says what am I doing here there's a cut
of him taking a pill we saw this bottle
of pills in the trailer and it says that
it's an antidepressant anti-anxiety
drugs zoloft that's what the bottle said
at least he's talking to Darlene who
says why are you trying to shut me out
there's a shot of Elliot going up in an
elevator with his hood on then a shot of
Joana riding in her SUV with a sly
looking smile and please look on her
face it looks like she's making that
face at someone and that it's in mid
conversation after that we see the shot
of Elliot slamming Darlene
to the wall from the earlier trailers
pops up next we see it zoom in on her
face and she says it's you here we have
to imagine and we in the longer version
of this in the trailer we saw that it
switches from a scene Elliott to us
seeing mr. robot originally I thought
that was the glitching kind of thing
that we saw in season 2 but what it
appears like now is that we're gonna be
seeing Elliott and not knowing whether
it's Elliott Elliott or if it's mr.
robot Elliott
so maybe perhaps whenever he's slamming
her against the wall she realizes it's
mr. robot and then we see it as
Christian Slater instead of rami malek
that's kind of interesting that when
we're seeing Elliott doing stuff we
might not know which Elliott it is I
don't have anything else to go off
except for that trailer so we'll have to
see how it plays out but I also wanted
to mention this Sam s male interview
that came out after episode 1 it was in
Entertainment Weekly and they asked him
some questions about the big device or
machine or Collider thing that we saw in
the first episode and it's interesting
what he said especially related to a
question about time travel because I
don't know if you never really followed
the theories and things on this I mean
there are some way out there ones I mean
they're all interesting for the most
part some of them are just way too
sci-fi for my tastes it doesn't mean
that they're not right it's just that I
don't believe that this is a sci-fi dedh
type show I think the stories a lot more
straightforward so a lot of these super
elaborate sci-fi theories just seem to
be unrelated to what we've actually seen
develop on the other hand there have
been a lot of back to the future to
references and we also have whiterose
who's obsessed with time so there is
some merit to this idea so the
interviewer asked Sam s Mel the director
series creator as a showrunner whatever
you want to call him this question first
the episode opens with a glimpse of some
enormous piece of machinery and there
seems to be a big answer
hidden in there is this mystery
something we can expect to be solved
this season SML answers and this is I'm
reading this directly from the article
white roses motivation has always been
shrouded in a lot of mystery for those
last two seasons even though I didn't
want to answer exactly what it was I
wanted to at least show the thing and I
wanted to drill down on her obsession to
control her reality visa vie this
technology she's producing that
parallels any real-life billionaire in
our world who's obsessed with technology
and makes these lofty claims whether
it's anti-aging or singularity or AI or
space we kind of wanted to model white
roses Ark on that level
what if someone with extreme wealth and
resources had this goal of being able to
control their own reality and they
really wanted to execute that through
technology that's as much as we want to
reveal right now the audience we're
going to give out more details later it
was important to set that up this season
because I think we've been teasing it
long enough we thought it was important
to at least show the thing even if
you're not exactly clear on what you're
seeing the interviewer then followed up
was a time travel question he said just
as a general question totally
disconnected from mr. robot do you think
season 3 of a television show is too
late to introduce the concept of time
travel
Sam SML answered and he was laughing he
says the problem with time travel I've
always said in the writers room that
whenever you introduce time travel it's
game over then all the rules go out the
window throwing out time travel in the
middle of a series run is a little late
now this isn't an actual flat-out denial
but I think it is a denial just the same
and I mentioned in my episode one recap
and review that I just never have seen
it going that way I followed most of the
theories on reddit and other places and
I've read them all there like I said
there's plenty of compelling ones I just
haven't adopted any of them as what I
think the show is going to do I could be
wrong but I
don't think so and I think this actually
backs that up I do think what he said
about White Rose is a lot more
interesting and I think it's a lot more
relevant to what's going on
in our lifetime wealth redistribution
going up to the top is something that's
been going on pretty consistently for
the past 40 years of course there's been
other periods in our history where
there's been that same kind of massive
wealth at the top but I mean there's
just a lot of billionaires out there now
and there's some of them are a little
bit wacky I'm not going to talk about
anybody in particular but when you get
into billions of dollars and tens of
billions of dollars you know that is an
amazing amount of resources and
whiterose is a pretty interesting
character because we know that there is
a real command of Technology there so I
really like this little nugget that he
threw out I think it's interesting I
would love to hear your theories about
what you think White Rose is up to I
think it does actually tie into that
thing being underneath the ground in New
Jersey as well I think that is the
Washington Township plant and that is
why White Rose is so obsessed with that
area but time will tell we don't know
for sure yet and that's about it for
this video thanks for watching please
like the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already
my next mr. robot video is going to be
Easter egg related it's gonna be a
collection of all the little things you
might have missed in the episode there
were quite a few prominent things that
stood out to me on first watch that I
didn't mention in my recap there is a
real noticeable QR code couple of URLs
things like that so I'm gonna put those
all together in a video that will come
out this weekend make sure you give me a
follow on Twitter and my other social
media accounts where we can interact
over there and take a moment to check
out my patreon and see if you want to
get involved what's that thanks for
watching guys I'll talk to you soon